по шоці уроку з приватних вас там
книжка лову ярмарок франкфурті було
індонезія політичне протистояння
mesh українську цю росію знову стала у
її азії головних тем такси в допомогу
категорично французької до чоловічої
ярмарок україна у паша представлена ​​про
край вам великим стендом росія знову
пеппа сила значного з найбільшими cc100
suite novotel cairo звірів стенді біля
українського видвидівця значними shiny
shoe по парі днів руку та
шукати page за всі книги про крим то
шляхів на сході України
нас устах з українським автором та аншлагу
такі інтереси до письма деяких не daewoo
я
клуб диму та контактне волосся в Європі
відриваючи вина відриваючи вина між вами
окраїна мої безладного на ціни можна
на рожевому зі можна було волієш
куди ще інтерес до України ви clock вона
і сама такими трагічними драматичними та
гинув від душу добрий ще й резонансу
теж добрий його буквально за сто метрів
презентація з чого днів книги російська
рефлекс написала два історики чи наш
щербакова за русь і така вже ліг з ними
чини їх не робота pro t2 ти взялася
адаптивно російського світу все крутиться
закрутиться дух колотого що треба ппш з
барахти владу дробовик ти людожер щуром
або соціальних проблем і трава придумати
укус скріплю я хто покаже російську і у
себе швидше за тата ви було всіх прикро
ти мала об'єднати до пішли вели
привезу франкфурті одну свою книгу
київської рішення з фотографію протестну
майдану на володієте
з прірву розумі ти вчора що встав
конфлікт на сході України
я думаю що це пов'язано з кризою я
думається пов'язана внутрішню залазю в
росії путін пишуть на cc той чоловік
хіба знає проблему розвідку
росії на початку
21 століття Росії на початку двадцять
першого століття була представлена ​​в
франкфурті та нижча точка зору на стенді
наяву ликова берлінського ви задоволення
не мати skype ракат мемуарів
екс-прем'єр-міністра України Миколи
азарова
правда про державний переворот
ви давність покажи нового вирішено пара
клас стоїть з литого як європе сhris
інтерес до української тематики йдіть і
просто немає януковича і про проблему
державного пара ворота і просто тисяч
залишилося а потім за ціною підйом і в не
мечі не душі у важливості жили тільки щоб
досвід на мемуари ми коди азарова на
велике говорять ви давній знак ладу в
5000 екземплярів продали лише половину